court
documents naming Jeffrey Epstein's
Associates to be unsealed here's what to
know this is from NBC News ABC
News all the newses are reporting this
but I got NBC right here what I love
about this headline they send out the
headline everyone goes crazy and I had
this
prediction look I it could still be
proven wrong but my
prediction before the year ended was
we're not really going to get the
Epstein CL
list we're not going to find out new
people okay and then 5 seconds later
this headline they were going to unseal
the Epstein Client List I said oh wow
man maybe I was totally proven wrong
that was fast that's the fastest I've
ever been proven wrong
huh but hold on here's the headline
court documents naming Jeffrey ep's
Associates to be unsealed what to know
subheader former President Clinton
Prince Andrew and others are expected to
be named hold
on
we we know that Bill Clinton was an
Epstein
associate we've known that for the
better part of 10 years okay we we we've
seen his name on the flight logs we've
seen pictures of Bill
Clinton with Jeffrey Epstein we know
that je that Bill Clinton flew all
around the world with Jeffrey Epstein on
the low
Express that he would when he wasn't
flying with Epstein because he was
borrowing his plane
I don't need to find out that Bill
Clinton is an Epstein associate prince
Andrew prince Andrew lost his job
working for his mom because we all know
that he he hung out with Epstein we have
pictures of of prince Andrew with
Jeffrey Epstein we have court
settlements where prince Andrew has paid
Jeffrey Epstein's former young ladies
okay we I don't I don't need to hear
about that I want to hear about the end
others that's what I want to hear
about I don't want the names that we
already know that's that's called a
limited hangout okay that is it's a term
that in intelligence circles and crisis
communication circles
where you're caught you're up against a
wall they got you dead to rights you've
been lying you've been lying you've been
denying you've been denying and now you
say okay what are we going to do I'm
going to give them something and so what
you do is you only give a little bit you
and in this case you would be giving
something that everyone already knows
yeah we already know that Bill Clinton
hung out with Jeffrey Epstein oh did did
Bill Gates hang out with him too yeah we
got pictures of that
also I don't want to hear about those
guys I mean I'll hear more I guess but I
want to hear about the guys that I
haven't heard about yet that's the first
thing I want get give us the real
epsteam Client List the names we haven't
heard more than that though the the
question that I want to know the answer
to with regard to Jeffrey Epstein
is who was he working
for
nothing about Jeffrey Epstein's life
really adds up very shady past he's got
this business associate slash romantic
partner whose father was mobbed up with
at least three intelligence agencies
around the world we know he was mobbed
up with British intelligence maybe
Russian intelligence and certainly
Israeli intelligence
okay we know that Jeffrey Epstein was
mobbed up with intelligence we know this
from Alex aasta who was us attorney
Prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein in Florida
who then was up for labor secretary
under Donald Trump and reportedly in his
interview when he was asked about the EP
prosecution he said I was
told not to really go too hard after
Epstein because Epstein quote belonged
to intelligence what intelligence I
don't know is all of that fake is that
all just fake news and weird
coincidences with gilain Maxwell's
Father Robert Maxwell uh maybe but I
want to
know was was Jeffrey
Epstein rigging up his properties to
record people engaging in weird illegal
sex stuff with underage
girls just to enrich Jeffrey Epstein
look maybe he was just a con artist a
blackmail artist who was shaking down
these rich guys to enrich himself could
be was this part of an intelligence
operation if so which intelligence was
he working for foreign
intelligence MI6 Israel
Russia or was he working for American
intelligence or was he working for lots
of different type of intell but I want
to
know less about the scintilating little
details of who did what with whom uh in
terms of what was going on in those
massage rooms I want to know who did
what with whom with regard to what was
this operation
for you know a thing by what it's for
what was this for what was what was the
Epstein weird sex Island and the pen
houses and the video cameras what was
that all in service
of trump Remains the top dog in the race
there was a change over the over the
break though and the change is that
there is another a number two dog in the
race who we haven't seen before and that
would be ncky Haley Ronda santis has
been the number two guy in the
Republican race for all of
2023 and he is still the number two guy
he's just the number two guy that's tied
with the number two lady
who is Nikki Haley now people are
shocked by this because people have very
strong feelings about Nikki Haley people
who are a little bit more
Centrist they really like Nikki Haley a
lot of the Republican Consultants really
like Nikki Haley they think that she's
got the best chance to beat Joe Biden
because she appeals to a broader array
of people conservatives often do not
like Nikki Haley they find her to be a
bit establishment a bit Bush era kind of
Republican a little eager to go invade
foreign countries and so they don't like
her and and some of the criticism from
the conservative side of the Republican
party has been intense at Nikki
haly but when Nikki announced that she
was running in this race you know I hate
to say I told you
so I believe I pointed out that one
should not count out Nikki Haley
everyone was making fun of her she's
going nowhere she has no constituency
her views out are outdated blah blah
blah all this stuff I said you guys
don't know what you're talking about
Nikki Haley is a very very talented
politician she managed think about this
she is one of if not the only politician
in America who has huge establishment
crit cred who has major cred among the
bush wi of the Republican
Party who did very very well under Trump
she served under Trump she was Trump's
face at the United Nations she was very
popular in that role when she left the
White House Trump basically gave her a
ticker parade okay he had that big press
conference sitting with her Nikki has
done a great job we really like her then
she turned on Trump then she turned back
and supported Trump then she kind of
turned on Trump again running against
him and still Trump is saying nice
things about her Nikki is very good at
politics so it is no surprise to me that
entering into 2024 she is now a number
two candidate in the race what we will
wait for this week and next week is can
Nikki kick disantis to number three
right now they're tied can she kick him
to number three I would not be surprised
as I said you know I hate to say I told
you so but as I said for a year Des
santis is great he's really great he's a
great Governor he's terrific I really
admire the guy he's fabulous but part of
the things that are really likable about
him to someone like me are going to make
him unpopular as a candidate because
he's a little too trumpy to attract The
Establishment Centrist folks but he's
not trumpy enough he's not Trump so he's
not going to pull enough of the Trump
voters which means that while he looks
like maybe he's the best candidate in
the race he's also a man without a home
man what a great clip that was now hold
up wait wait ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see
you next time